While the metaphor of paper and
ink are useful, we'll still
designing for digital medium.
So we shouldn't be limited by those
pesky rules of physics like their real
world equivalents.
Material surfaces have some unique
properties that bring them to life, and
let your applications
connect with users.
Material surfaces can be created and
destroyed, they can change shape,
split apart or rejoin like this example.
Similarly, a section of the surface
that is ink components can lift out and
form their own surface.
You can see this happening in
this parent to child example.
Where a list item lifts out and
expands to become the detail screen.
These material properties can help you
to create immersive applications that
respond to interaction,
rather than jumping into new states,
making them easier to comprehend.
We'll expand on using
motion in lesson four.